We now want to look at some key.
terms
and notation that we
have to be very clear about right from the start.
These are terms that we will come across again
that again and again
not just in this tutorial, but
In statistics and probability Theory altogether there
are some things you need to know about.
The notation that is not apparent that is
not explicit, especially when it comes to random variables
and events.
There is some concept that is implied, but it
is not actually expressed mathematically.
So you want to both pay attention?
to the terms
that we are going to talk about now and the notation.
you may even have to come back to this video at a
later point just to
review
while we were talking about now.
because it's
easy to forget
or confuse the terms because they are not intuitive.
But anyway, let's begin first.
with four words
outcome
event
sample space
and experiment
they would experiment is to perform an action.
That produces an outcome.
for example flipping a coin
When if the action of flipping a coin
is an experiment?
The action of rolling a dice is an experiment.
Taking a picture of something is an experiment.
Pressing the light switch is an experiment.
now if you press the light switch
you can have two possible outcomes.
Either the light will be turned on.
Or the light will be turned off.
if you take a picture you have
infinitely many outcomes
It can be a picture of a cat.
It could be a picture of yourself.
You get the idea?
when you
flip a coin
when you perform this experiment the outcome could
be either heads or tails.
Now it's also important to keep in mind that an
outcome.
Can sometimes be numerical?
But sometimes it could be a picture or a
word or a sound.
So we can have different and the word is modalities or
different data types if you like.
Your performance experiment?
You get an outcome?
Now suppose we perform five experiments.
And now you have five outcomes.
If you put these five outcomes into a set.
We call this an event.
So an event is a collection of outcomes.
Let's say now you perform seven.
More experiments so you get seven more outcomes.
Those seven outcomes will allow also be in a set
which you call an event. So now you have two.
You have two sets you have two events.
Event one with five outcomes.
Event 2 with 7 outcomes if
you put these two events together.
Or more generally speaking.
the collection of all of your events
is what we call the sample space.
I'm going to show you a picture now, but keep in mind.
The term sample space comes from probability
Theory.
And do not want to create some association with the
word sample in statistics.
These are two different fields.
And they use the word sample, but they use the word sample to
mean to different things.
So here's a picture to describe what
I just said visually.
So we said we have an experiment which is some action.
That produces an outcome.
like flipping a coin
you flip the coin.
And you get a tails?
You flip a coin you get a heads.
so in the event
We'll have multiple outcomes or I should say can have multiple
outcomes.
in this figure, I'm only putting one outcome, but
An event can contain multiple outcomes.
And then you can perform more experiments.
Without comments that will go inside another event. So earlier I said
you have one event with for example five outcomes.
You have another event with for example 7 outcomes if
you put your events if you take all of your
events.
However, many they are.
If you would all ever events into another set.
This one set that contains all of your events is
what we call.
the sample space